possible note and of course you already
know who's coming next victor Davis
Hansen is senior fellow at the Hoover
institution joins us for the two minutes
and 10 seconds we have left Professor
welcome
thank you well Tucker I think that we're
have we're seeing War clouds gather
abroad and I think the United States
economy politically foreign policy is it
a nadir and we've lost now all
credibility that we've stored up over
233 we have no more moral credibility to
lecture people about the Democratic
process and your guests have spelled it
out pretty well they have an agenda the
left that does not appeal to 51 percent
of the people so they attack the process
and they attack the candidate and what's
we're seeing is not the end of it this
tonight was the very beginning this is
going to go on through three prosecutors
for a year and a half with the intent of
getting just enough empathy for Donald
Trump that he nominated and then seeing
him gag ordered Hemorrhage and maybe
even incarcerated to nullify his
viability in the general election so
it's the worst example of third world
election tampering and they don't have a
message and so whether it's symbolically
tearing up the state of the union or
denying and the speaker of the minority
leader in the house appointments are
trying to threaten the filibuster to be
ended or the Electoral College or pack
the court it's all processed because
they don't have a message and they're
desperate they're revolutionaries we're
in the middle of a revolution we don't
even know that we're in I think Donald
Trump said it much as he could but I
imagine that in the next week we'll see
a gag order leveled against him and then
the other prosecutors will be encouraged
and this is going to go on this cycle
drama is going to go on for a year and a
half
which is entirely the point very quickly
is there not a single Democrat in
Washington who cares about the country
enough to say what you just said
I don't think so I think some people
like Joe manchin have spoken out but
there's no Democratic party anymore it
doesn't exist it's it's not even a
progressive party if it's a woke
hardcore leftist revolutionary movement
and has no popular support but
throughout history such such movements
didn't really need they didn't need it
thank you so much subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight